ah
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y les voy a comentar acerca de mi
experiencia de cómo fue tener que salir
dos veces del closet
cuando una persona heterosexual piensa
en el closet seguramente piensa pues en
un mueble en donde guardan sus
pertenencias en donde guardan su ropa o
en donde guardan sus zapatos pero cuando
nosotros los lgtb pensamos en el closet
pues pensamos en un espacio donde
solamente escuchamos nuestra propia voz
donde únicamente escuchamos nuestra
vergüenza donde encontramos muchísimo
aislamiento pero también es un espacio
seguro es un espacio libre de
discriminación y es por eso que el
closet existe
quisiera comenzar esta plática
preguntándole a las personas
heterosexuales aquí presentes cuántos de
ustedes tuvieron que plantarse frente a
sus padres y decirles papá mamá qué
crees soy heterosexual por supuesto que
nadie por qué porque se considera que
ser heterosexual es lo bueno es lo
normal es lo saludable y por el
contrario ser parte de la comunidad lgtb
es lo peor que le puede pasar a una
persona no cuando yo salí del clóset por
primera vez lo hice lleno de miedo pero
bueno esto fue cuando tenía 17 años pero
ya desde mucho antes yo sabía que era
diferente desde que era un niño pequeño
e iba a la escuela así con mi mochila de
las tortugas ninja sobre la espalda y
pues era una cosita de este tamaño yo
sabía que era diferente
hablaba diferente caminaba diferente
pero no sabía en qué consistía mi
diferencia ya cuando llegué más o menos
a la pubertad y cuando pues el cuerpo se
cubre de pelo y cuando también nos sale
un montón de acné en la cara fue cuando
dije de ahí más o menos viene mi
diferencia porque la mayoría de mis
compañeros estaban pues en su propio
universo no mientras la mayoría de mis
compañeritos estaban viendo a mis
compañeras o llevaban a escondidas sus
revistas estas de muchachas voluptuosas
lo que yo hacía en ese momento era tener
mis ojos puestos en mis otros
compañeritos en los muchachos que veían
pasar por la calle o incluso en los
modelos estos en bikini que vemos en las
tiendas de ropa interior
entonces ahí es cuando supe a que esto
iba me diferencia
sin embargo pues también ahí fue cuando
que conocí el peso del primer closet
porque porque fue también cuando le tuve
muchísimo miedo a muchas palabras que
hieren y que lastiman escuché por
primera vez palabras como [ __ ] palabras
como [ __ ] palabras como puñal
verdad que son palabras que son
incómodas y fuertes y que no quisiéramos
escuchar y que mejor volteamos hacia
otro lado pues ahora imagínense como le
duelen esas palabras a un adolescente de
12 o 13 años que apenas va descubriendo
su orientación sexual y entonces es por
eso que nos refugiamos en el closet las
personas lgp
cuando decidí empoderar me un poco más y
salir del closet con mi familia le dije
a mi mamá mamá soy gay por supuesto que
hubo algunas lágrimas por ahí pero
después ella tuvo una actitud ejemplar
me abrazó y me protegió con mis amigos
la cosa fue un poquito distinta con mis
amigos les dije oigan soy gay y ellos me
dijeron güey
si no nos dices no nos damos cuenta no
estás como una especie de vitrina y de
cristal y vienes y nos dices que eres
gay pero bueno el caso es que ellos
aunque lo tomaron un poco a chiste
ninguno de ellos me rechazó me quisieron
y me abrazaron entonces ya me sentí un
poco más empoderado sin embargo conocí
pronto una palabra que me daba más pavor
que todas las otras palabras que les
mencioné anteriormente y esa palabra era
sidoso porque en aquellos tiempos tan
todos los medios de comunicación
hablaban del sida y nos machacaban que a
nosotros los lg
nos iba a matar el sida ya fueran las
revistas ya fuera el cine o incluso las
canciones nos decían eres hot te vas a
morir de sida punto no hay vuelta de
hoja
no y a mí mi hermano mayor me cantaba en
son de burla la canción de el gran varón
de willie colon esta canción que a la
mejor ahorita nos da quizá un poco de
risa hasta ahorita ya lo acabo de
escuchar con ustedes pero a mí me daba
pavor ser el gran varón porque porque en
esa canción él se muere de una extraña
enfermedad
la canción nunca lo menciona pero en
realidad él muere de sida
entonces pues por supuesto que nos da
pánico y entonces yo dije pues ya mi
modo no voy a tener que morirme de eso y
lo asumí como una especie de maldición
más adelante cuando empecé mis ires y
venires en el mundo gay me di cuenta de
que aunque había muchas oportunidades
para ejercer mi libertad sexual lo mío
era más bien soñar con una pareja
monógama pues ya saben con todo el
paquete completo de casa perro hijos
todo este idilio bonito que uno piensa
no del matrimonio y tal y dije pues a la
mejor si es que yo vivo mi sexualidad
por ahí a la mejor si lo vivo así no me
va a tocar el sida no más adelante
conocí a una pareja tenía una
exclusividad sexual con él y cuando pasó
esto él me juraba y perjuraba que nunca
había estado con nadie más y que estando
conmigo no se metía con nadie más
entonces por lo tanto yo pensé dije pues
no me hago ningún examen no primer
gravísimo error
fue hasta años después cuando me di
cuenta de que algo no estaba bien un día
empecé a sudar frío un día empecé a
tener temblores terribles en el cuerpo
un día empecé a tener fiebre altísimas y
yo pensé dije a lo mejor es la influenza
la famosa fiebre porcina no pero no no
era eso sin embargo me empecé a tomar
analgésicos como si fueran caramelos no
y dije bueno voy a seguir trabajando
aquí no está pasando absolutamente nada
hasta que un día no me pude levantar de
la cama así fue y fue cuando llegué al
hospital y el médico me dijo está
respirando como un paciente de cáncer
terminal de pulmón ahí fue cuando dije
pero qué puede estar pasando yo nunca en
la vida había fumado un cigarrillo el
médico me hizo un montón de exámenes y
fue ahí cuando salió que yo vivía con
vih en ese momento yo no tuve la
oportunidad de seleccionar las palabras
ni el momento adecuado para salir de ese
segundo closet
porque fueron los médicos los que le
dijeron a mi familia que yo vivía no
solo cambie y h olvídense del vih que yo
ya había presentado sida no sé si
ustedes lo sepan pero una persona se
dice que tiene sida cuando tiene menos
de 200 células de cd4 en la sangre de
los cd4 son estos como anticuerpos que
nos permiten pues librar la batalla
contra los agentes externos en ese
momento yo no sólo no tenía ni los 200
saben cuantos tenía tenía 18
entonces estaba ya postrado en la cama
de un hospital por una neumonía
fulminante me dieron un tratamiento
agresivo y ximo estuve en coma inducido
estuve intubado estuve en terapia
intensiva durante aproximadamente un mes
y la verdad es que fue de las cosas más
terribles que me han tocado vivir los
médicos decían que había un 85% de
probabilidad de que muriera contra un 15
de sobrevivir pero sobrevivir
sin embargo el estar ahí en esa sala de
hospital es de las cosas que no le deseo
a absolutamente nadie imagínense en el
pabellón de infectología estábamos todas
esas personas que de verdad nos iban a
arrumbar ahí como si fuéramos trebejos
completamente inservibles y que éramos
los que ya no teníamos ninguna solución
todos los días en los momentos en los
que yo estaba inconsciente de lo que yo
estaba consciente perdón veía morir por
lo menos una o dos personas y era la
cosa más horrible porque veía los
camilleros entrar los veía cubrir los
cuerpos y los veía sacarlos de ahí como
si fueran basura y también escuchaban
los gritos desgarradores de las familias
y también era una especie de ruleta rusa
macabra en la cual uno no sabía si uno
iba a ser el siguiente en el que se iba
a morir
poco tiempo después logré salir del
hospital y gracias a que logré salir del
hospital
pues estuve pues en contacto ya con mi
tratamiento antiretroviral lo empecé a
tomar me pegue a él de una manera súper
súper súper religiosa y no en el sentido
religioso de persignarme sino en el
sentido religioso de que me toca a las
10 de la noche a las 10 de la noche me
lo tomo y en unos pocos meses ocurrió
algo que yo considero un milagro no
solamente ya no presentaba ciudad sino
que tenía mi carga viral indetectable de
haber sido una persona que salió del
hospital en silla de ruedas de haber
sido una persona que no podía ni caminar
y que salió con un generador de oxígeno
que le ayudaba a respirar porque ni
siquiera podía respirar por mí mismo
ahora estaba en indetectable entonces
empecé a tener otra vez vida sentimental
y vida sexual que por supuesto lo hacía
con muchísima culpa y ahí es cuando
conoció otra vez el peso del segundo
closet porque a pesar de que yo era
indetectable
pues yo sentía mucha culpa no sé si
ustedes lo sepan hace ratito el doctor
baluchi les dijo indetectable igual en
transmisibles eso quiere decir que a
pesar bueno que si uno ya está en el
estatus de detectable ya no transmite el
virus a las personas y sin embargo yo
sentía que no les tenía que ocultar eso
ni a mis ligas ocasionales ni a mis
potenciales parejas
por fortuna ninguno de los novios que
tuve en estos momentos tuvieron problema
con el virus terminamos por otras
razones pero no por cosas asociadas al
virus
y después un poco más adelante conocía
el correcto
no sé si lo logren ver desde ahí donde
están ahí arriba o aquí enfrente pero
aquí en la mano izquierda
tengo un anillo de bodas
apenas hace un par de meses me casé de
hecho mi esposo está que acompañándome y
es
una persona
es una persona increíble y es una
persona incondicional porque cuando yo
le dije de mi estatus el es negativo y
cuando yo le dije de mi estatus él me
dijo y qué se supone que tenía que
hacerte un drama o algo así tú sigues
siendo la misma persona de la cual yo me
enamoré y eso es algo que de verdad se
lo desearía a todas las personas y ese
es el mensaje con el que quiero que
vivan todos los demás que en el momento
en que se empoderen las personas
positivas y que decidan salir de este
segundo closet no reciban ni rechazo ni
burlas ni discriminación que así como yo
que así como mi familia me quiso y me
arropó como mis amigos me quisieron y me
arroparon así a ustedes les pase
absolutamente lo mismo y a las personas
que son negativas aquí les quiero pedir
encarecidamente un gran favor por favor
hablen de vih aunque ustedes no lo
porten no importa
infórmense de conceptos que son super
sencillos como
digamos la carga viral que son los cd4
cuál es la diferencia entre vih/sida
hablen hablen de ello sin esta carga
moral sólo así vamos a lograr que el día
de mañana más personas lo puedan
comentar más personas puedan salir a
hacerse una prueba y lo hagan sin culpa
ésta pudo ser la diferencia que me pudo
haber ahorrado el miedo de haberme ido a
detectar a tiempo porque yo lo que
sentía cuando me dice él cuando no me
hice la prueba fue por miedo entonces si
ustedes pueden por favor hablen de vih y
háganlo sin ninguna clase de juicio
moral sólo entonces cuando le quitemos
esa carga moral al vih sólo entonces
podremos decir que hemos superado una de
las más grandes pruebas y podremos decir
hacia el futuro se acuerdan cuando le
temíamos algo que es literalmente tan
chiquito como un virus dentro de nuestro
organismo y entonces todos tanto los que
somos positivos como quiénes
son negativos podamos vivir juntos en
armonía y muy muy felices muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]